Alex Madison I'm the Hudson River keeper
which means I'm the chief advocate of
the Hudson River and I'm also the
president of the organization that goes
by the same name riverkeeper
okay very good question and surprisingly
i would guess that you surveyed New
Yorkers on the street only a small
fraction of them would actually know
where their water comes from they might
have some vague idea that comes from
somewhere out of state but in fact New
York City and Westchester County so 8
million from the five boroughs of New
York City plus a million from
Westchester County 9 million total get
their daily drinking water supply from a
2,000 square mile area that mostly is in
the Catskills 1,500 acres sorry 1,500
square miles of that of that is in the
Catskill Mountains and then the other
500 square miles is throughout Putnam in
Westchester County the system is
basically based on capturing rainwater
from rainfall that is moved down the
mountainside and obviously gets
collected through the system of streams
and reservoirs some natural reservoirs
natural lakes and other man-made lakes
19 of them in total the capture that
water and then through a series of
aqueducts that were built starting in
the mid 19th century all the way to the
early part of the 20th century I'll make
their way through gravitation there's no
pumps involved at all this is in other
word basically from the source up in the
Catskills down to New York City there is
an elevation drop it is very very small
you know per foot per mile but it isn't
enough to keep the water moving through
gravitation down to the cities uh you
know buildings and internal pipes so
that's essentially where the water comes
from about ninety percent of the supply
the 1.5 billion gallons that come to new
york city every day comes from the
Catskill Delaware system essentially
which is basically the Catskill
watershed which is the water that falls
east off of the Catskill Mountains and a
Delaware watershed which falls West off
the Catskill Mountains and eventually
would have made it its way down to the
Delaware River were it not captured in
these upstate reservoirs so ninety
percent comes from that source it's a
very very clean source because of the
relatively minor amount of development
up in that region the ten percent
roughly that
comes from the east of Hudson system or
the the westchester and putnam system
actually is not quite as clean and it's
it's safe enough to drink but it's much
more has much more pressure on it and is
much more exposed to potential
contaminants because of the heavy
development has happened when in putnam
in westchester over the last you know 50
to 100 years just to back up a second
but New Yorkers may not know that
they're the source of their drinking
water is unfiltered its treated with a
little bit of chlorine to hit basic
pathogens is treated with a little bit
of fluoride for to promote or to avoid
tooth decay and beyond that it's not
filters one of the last remaining
unfiltered system so that's why it
tastes so delicious and it's so clean
the problem is you've got to then
protect the water at its source up in
the Catskills and in east of hudson
unfortunately because of all the
development of east of hudson part of
the system the epa decided in New York
you got to build a filtration plant
that's the only way you can absolutely
safeguard that part of the water supply
the problem is of course is once you
build that filtration plant it takes
pressure off of New York City off of the
of those upstate communities who live in
the watershed to actually protect the
water at source and a filtration plant
is not bulletproof you can still have
pathogens get through a filtration plant
and cause outbreaks of disease
well Riverkeeper was part of an historic
agreement in 1997 called the watershed
agreement and it was an agreement
between new york city and the state of
New York and the upstate communities who
live again in these watershed areas
there's been a long-standing tension
between the upstate communities who feel
like New York is robbing their their
their their water and not only that but
because of the need to protect the area
is also restricting their opportunity
for economic growth mechanoid
development and then New York it had to
balance that that frustration and also
make sure that it repays those upstate
communities in some ways so in order to
protect the source of our drinking water
and to make sure that we remained in
unfiltered supply or we continue to
enjoy an unfiltered supply we reach this
agreement between environmental groups
like Riverkeeper the state of New York
upstate communities New York City and
basically it's set out a series of
requirements that New York had to follow
in order to protect that upstate source
but also to help promote some
sustainable economic growth up in that
region to provide jobs and you know
economic stimulus so among those things
are acquiring land you need buffer lands
especially around the streams and the
reservoirs itself so that pollution
erosion sediment etc salt from the route
from nearby road doesn't run into the
reservoirs and of course end up in our
drinking water supply you also need to
especially in the east of Hudson system
you need to upgrade sewage treatment
plants that are in some cases are 40 50
years old they're starting to fail
they're starting to discharge untreated
or partially treated sewage into our
water system now again by the time that
makes its way down to New York City
through natural systems and microbes and
so on that is treated but nonetheless
you don't want to have that too much of
that so you've got to upgrade the sewage
treatment plants you've got to help
homeowners to upgrade their septic
systems where you don't have sewage
treatment etc so Riverkeeper plays the
role of being the watchdog making sure
that new york city and its environmental
agency the dep
Department of Environmental Protection
is doing all the things that they agreed
to do in that 1997 agreement
unfortunately their track record has
been very mixed and now it very much
depends on who the mayor of New Yorkers
of time when you had mayor Giuliani this
is something he did not think was a
priority he did not put a commissioner
in the DEP who thought it was a priority
either and there was a lot of kind of
shenanigans going on and a lot of
cutting of budgets and not putting
enforcement officers up in the watershed
to make sure that the source for water
is protected Mayor Bloomberg has been
much better but still it's an old agency
and they've got a certain bureaucratic
ways of doing things they've got certain
kind of agency resistance that that
makes it difficult sometimes to get them
to do everything needed to do but
Riverkeeper plays a role of being
watchdog to make sure they do is we're
supposed to do now the other threat
especially to the ninety percent that
comes from the catskill system is that
development pressures in this in the
Catskills have quadrupled over the last
you know seven years particularly since
911 there was a there was a migration of
some New Yorkers who left New York City
after 911 because of you know the fear
of terrorism and so on and a lot of them
ended up going up to the Catskill
regions which is only you know a couple
hours away to settle and with those
additional people suddenly developers
started to see dollar signs and saw the
Catskills as a potential economic boom
area it is it's a gorgeous area you've
got the advantage of obviously having a
little bit higher unemployment up there
so there is a real hunger for jobs that
which means that the local
municipalities are going to be generally
supportive of whatever kind of
development comes up there so there's
really an increasing amount of pressure
to develop that area and if we do that
and we don't do it right and suddenly
that ninety percent starts to get
contaminated in a way that it really
hasn't been to date then suddenly new
york city is looking at having to build
potentially a filtration plant for that
west of hudson part of the system that
ninety percent which would cost current
estimates are 10 to 12 billion dollars
and you're talking about an annual
operation maintenance costs of about
half a billion dollars per year so you
can imagine New Yorkers water rates will
go through the roof so it's not that's
not a scenario that we want
there is something that we looked into
very rigorously around you know I'm not
long after the 911 attacks it became an
obvious question if you're looking at
new york's new york city in particular
the New York region's infrastructure
what are the potential vulnerable points
well obviously the Indian Point nuclear
power plant is one of those the chemical
plants over New Jersey or another but
certainly our water supply supplies
vital I mean Manhattan and the
surrounding five boroughs would not
survive very long without a source of
water because most of them whatever I
mean almost all that actually does come
from from upstate so clearly that was
concerned we did some investigation
there's two couple conclusions we came
to which put us at ease first of all the
BP did step up their enforcement
presence up in the watershed to make
sure their security up there near the
aqueducts near the Kensico reservoir
where a lot of the water comes through
to make sure that those areas were
protected from some kind of you know
attempt to blow up you know the dam or
blow up yeah the Kensico reservoir and
so that was somewhat assuring secondly
in terms of if if of terrorists was to
dump some kind of chemical agent or
mercury or something that's highly toxic
they could pollute the entire system and
poison New Yorkers by the time that that
was done word would get out the DP would
know about it and New Yorkers would of
course be warned not to drink any of the
water so in terms of actually being
successful in killing New Yorkers by
contaminating the water supply you know
it takes 60 to 90 days if you drop a
drop of water and these in some of the
Upstate reservoirs for it to make its
way through the system down into your
taps here in New York City but
nonetheless they could contaminate the
upstate supply and heavily disrupt New
York City because if we were obviously
without water for some time until we
could treat or or deal with the
poisoning of our system then certainly
that would disrupt the city
well the Hudson is actually a terrific
success story is it's it's it's hailed
internationally as a model of waterway
restoration because of Riverkeepers work
on the Hudson River and helping to
restore the river which we've been
largely successful at over the last 40
years along and in coalition with many
other environmental groups and concerned
citizens and so on this is become as I
said a model for waterway restoration
and Reba keeper has become a model for
one or clean water advocacy Riverkeepers
the first Waterkeeper if you will we
were started in 1966 there are now a
hundred and seventy-five other water
keepers working locally to protect their
sounds and their bays and their coastal
areas and their lakes and streams all
over the world I think we're on six
continents now 15 to 20 countries so
we're the fastest growing grassroots
environmental organization in the world
and it's all based on a very simple
model which is local people taking into
their own hands the need and the
responsibility and the privilege of
working on a restoring the local
waterway that's been abused through you
know decades or centuries if you will of
industrial activity so it's a terrific
success story I would guess it if the
Hudson River was a 10 you rated a 10 you
know when when the Lenape Indians we're
living along as shores and before
Columbus showed up it was probably a 2
by the mid 60s and we got our start and
I'd say we're probably roughly seven
today that's that's that's real progress
and you know you can swim the length of
the Hudson on most days in most areas of
the Hudson absolutely safely and people
do that by the thousands every spring
and summer and fall there are some
problems with funding which I'll get to
in a second but people are back out on
the river fishing before picnicking
kayaking in record numbers the bald
eagles have returned to the Hudson in
droves you know the ecologically
speaking the Hudson has really come back
2022 you know not not not a fully
restored river but but but but but but
much much better than it was in the past
you know it were in good shape
relatively speaking however that's not
to say there aren't some remaining
obstacles and they're been there serious
ones one is General Electric as
everybody knows dumped 1.3 million
pounds of PCBs polychlorinated biphenyls
which are highly toxic to humans into
animals into the river up around hudson
falls over a 40-year period a 30 year
period from the mid 40s to the mid 70s
they those PCBs were banned in the 70s
but the damage had been done the PCBs
had made their way throughout the Upper
Hudson in the lower part of the of the
river the estuary and and spread
throughout the entire ecosystem the
Hudson River as a result is the largest
Superfund site in the country we have
been working for 30 years again in
coalition with some of our other
environmental partners and concerned
citizens to try and force General
Electric to clean up that mess and at
this point they can't mean they can't
meaningfully remove PCBs from the lower
part of the Hudson because they're so
dispersed it would be impossible to try
and and collect them but the 40 mile
stretch between their facilities of in
Hudson Falls and the federal dam at Troy
is a as a hot spots just PCBs shore to
shore bank to bank and there's a great
opportunity to clean those up because
that 40 mile stretch serves as an
ongoing source of 500 pounds of PCBs
that come over the dam every every year
down to the lower s2 airy and that means
that the the PCB levels and fish are
being maintained at a levels that are
too high that exceed the FDA and EPA
regulations so that's why we had to
close a number of the commercial
fisheries on the Hudson like the striped
bass and eel and others because of a PCB
contamination so until we remove you
know the couple hundred thousand pounds
of PCBs are in that hot spot area we're
not going to remove or eliminate the
source of PCBs down a lower part of the
river and until we do that we won't be
able to be open those those fisheries so
that's one issue another issue is sewage
you know the Clean Water Act helped us
to force municipalities to build these
sewage plants up and down the river
but now these plants are 30 40 years old
some of them and they're starting to
fail so we need serious help from the
federal government particularly from the
state government as well to get these
municipalities the money they need to
upgrade or to replace these these these
plants because we're now starting to
have ongoing regular discharges
unintended discharges of raw or
partially treated sewage into the Hudson
and if we continue at this pace swimming
the Hudson at one point will no longer
be safe and even now you don't want to
swim after it's been raining near one of
these two extreme plants especially ones
that combine their sewage in their storm
water because you almost certainly will
have a discharge so it's a major problem
in New York City it's a major problem in
Albany it's a problem Yonkers and some
of the other larger towns along the
river so you know there's definitely
still a number of issues that are
concerned one more that I just really
want to mention because it reflects a
new report that we're just about to
issue which is despite what we had
thought while there were improvements
over the last 40 years a lot of the
signature fish of a Hudson are actually
in various states of decline 10 of the
13 fish that our researchers looked at
are in various states of decline time at
the American shed the Atlantic sturgeon
the tomcod the L American eel these fish
are in trouble and there's all kinds of
possible explanations one is actually
global warming potentially we've already
started to see the Hudson River average
temperatures going up by a couple
degrees even now and that can radically
affect a lot of these species ability to
to come up into the river and spawn
reproduce successfully secondly you've
got a lot of invasive species like the
zebra mussel which have radically
changed the food chain and in the Hudson
and basically removed a lot of
zooplankton other food sources for some
of these fish you've got these old five
old antiquated power plants in the
Hudson which withdraw huge volumes of
water from Hudson every single day
Indian Point which is the nuclear
facility alone withdraws 2.4
gallons per day from the Hudson that is
almost twice as all of New York City
combined uses on a daily basis in terms
of water consumption so this one plan is
causing enormous impacts
well the issues with Indian Point quite
simply are that it's a nuclear power
plant that's got a long history of
safety and security problems at the
plant it's historically one of the worst
rated and worst run plants in the nation
there's two reactors there are two
working reactors and then there was a
third there was decommissioned back in
us in the 70s but you essentially have a
plant that that shuts down accidentally
at a rate five to six times the national
average in terms of all all the
different plants around the country
you've got an emergency plan that as a
joke on its face James Lee wit who is
the country's leading expert on
emergency planning he was the former
director of FEMA for ten years under
President Clinton and he came in he was
hired by Governor Pataki to look at the
evacuation plan of the of the plant and
determined that it was essentially
unworkable and the reasons are obvious
first of all you've got high population
density in the Westchester lower Hudson
Valley New York metropolitan area 20
million people live within a 50-mile
radius of the Indian Point plan that
includes out on to Long Island all five
boroughs of New York City Western
Connecticut northeastern New Jersey and
you know the the mid to lower hudson
valley so it's a lot of people who were
in what the NRC the Nuclear Regulatory
Commission itself calls the peak injury
zone a 50-mile radius you've got a very
congested road network throughout West
Chester and throughout the Hudson Valley
New York metropolitan area so if you
would have even a minor accident
especially a major accident you have a
massive exodus and it's not just the
people within the ten-mile evacuation
zone that that that the NRC pretends are
the only ones of concern here you know
come on if you live anywhere in
westchester new york city and so on you
hear there's been a major accident at
Indian Point you're going to be you're
going to do whatever you can to get out
of the area I mean if you look at
Chernobyl and the area of that covered
well that would go you know if you if
you were to superimpose a map of
Chernobyl and all the contaminated areas
that were that were
affected by the Chernobyl accident on a
map of the United States which noble
being right we're in the end point is
you'd be reaching up into Canada down to
the Carolinas it's a massive area now I
want to be clear the way that an
accident could happen at any point would
be different than Chernobyl the designs
are very different but the point is if
you had an accident at Indian Point and
you had a major release of radiation it
would be it was spelled absolute
disaster for not only New York where her
where the world's financial system is
centered but also for the world economy
I me of being you can't imagine an
accident that we more disastrous for for
for New York for the US and for the
world
well there's there's plenty of
alternative sources and this is one of
the you know the issues that the company
that owns Indian Point has worked very
hard to scare the public about which is
the idea that there's no way you can
replace Indian points power and if you
do the subways will shut down and so on
first of all it's just not the way
electricity works you've gotta you know
all kinds of providers power generators
who are contributing to the system and
when one plant goes down others kick in
and provide power so there's no one
plant that provides power for the subway
or for JFK airport or any specifics
facility it's all intermixed there are
plenty of alternatives first of all
you've got a very substantial wind
potential in New York State and we've
already have 800 megawatts on contract
or in contract for the state of New York
to be built you've also got excess
supplies in both the New England grid in
the New Jersey Maryland Delaware grid as
much as thirty to thirty-five percent
which we can import some of that in this
into the city if we were to closing the
point for instance right away you've
also got the potential to repower a lot
of existing old dirty plants throughout
the Hudson Valley in New York
metropolitan area that are coal oil
plants for instance that are highly
inefficient that pollute the air as it
is and if you repower them you could
probably double the amount of power
depends on the case but you could as
much as double the power being generated
from those plants right now and you dude
you would reduce your air pollution by
ninety-seven ninety-eight percent so
there's lots of different opportunities
obviously energy efficiency is another
way where you can actually shave
substantial amounts of power for instant
Ian point produces about 2,000 megawatts
of power and we've done studies
independent studies that show that if
you just apply to a relatively rigorous
energy efficiency program in New York
State you could save that much power as
well
well Riverkeeper is really focused on
protecting you know the Hudson River New
York City drinking water supply so we
don't tend to get into the larger issues
but I'll say this about nuclear power
it's a frustrating source of power
because on the one hand there's no
energy source that with such a small
relatively small amount of material
produces so much power so the potential
of this technology is incredible the
problem is of course is that not only
have we not figured out how we're going
to store it safely have we not figured
out how to get gain full control over
avoiding nuclear proliferation some of
the plutonium and other substances
getting into the hands of the wrong
people not only have we not fully dealt
with the issue of accidents and what
would happen in case of an accident but
this is not an economic source of power
if you were to remove all the subsidies
that the US government and thus
taxpayers provide to make the nuclear
industry viable the industry never would
have gotten off the ground we wouldn't
have a single plant in this country it's
the most heavily subsidized of all the
energy sources so I would welcome the
day and I think that we should continue
to research nuclear fusion and fission
to see if there are ways to improve on
the current model because of again the
potential to produce so much power from
so little material but we've got to
solve those problems of storage and
waste and proliferation if we're going
to make nuclear a viable future source
I tell you I think the simple answer to
two or not is a rephrase that and it's
actually not so simple but i think that
key to environmental problems in general
and energy issues in particular is that
we need attacks we wore a cap and
auction program a training program is a
different way to do it but i think you
need to make make it expensive to emit
carbon and frankly admit other
pollutants into the atmosphere and
expensive to to pollute our waterways
and so on and until you do that i think
that the risk we run is that all the
green work that we're doing has become
so popular over the last year too is
just a passing fad you really have to
make polluting costs money for these out
for these companies and in terms of an
energy policy again there's no quicker
way to start to develop all these
promising technologies in terms of the
biofuels and solar and wind and
geothermal and and sell fuel technology
and so on until gasoline and oil that
comes prohibitively expensive and you
know i'm not saying this you should be
unfairly taxed the problem is is that
those again those fuel sources have been
subsidized for so long that we are not
capturing the true cost of using those
sources you know in terms of all the
money that goes into building our
national highway system all the health
impacts that burning fossil fuels have
on our health the climate change impacts
that were there coming down the road
that we're already seeing what you're
going to have huge economic impacts on
our economy and so on so the key in my
view is to is to make carbon emissions
cost real money and the only real way
the most efficient way to do that is
through a carbon tax
well
the truth is that the environmental
movement in my view has been enormously
successful in its you know modern
incarnation you know meaning from the
late 60s early 70s when we passed our
modern environmental laws till now we've
had cute huge gains here we eliminated
ozone polluting chemicals and and we've
done a lot but the problem is is that
we're such a specialized country that
it's really been left up mostly to
environmental groups environmentalists
to do this work and we've been up
against enormous odds even up against
these corporations that you know the way
the system works don't have a real clear
financial interest in protecting the
environment all the time and frankly the
government doesn't do a very good job of
enforcing the laws which is another
regulatory way to stop companies from
polluting and you have certainly the
concern of a lot of Americans who
support us but they've got a million
concerns and the environment often has
kind of ranked low so it's been the
environmentalist and the environmental
groups kind of working on their own with
vastly with a vast gap in some sort of
resources you know to take on some of
these these colossally large expensive
programs so I think one of the things
that was one of the results of that has
been that our progress has been
relatively incremental and because of
that we are now starting to realize that
some of the gains we've that we've made
haven't been nearly enough and you're
starting to see real kind of ecological
crisis and collapse potential for
collapse you know when you're talking
about our fisheries our air quality you
know record level asthma rates a change
in climb and so on so suddenly are you
know mother nature is speaking back to
us and telling us that whatever progress
we've made isn't nearly enough and we
got to do a lot more so I think in order
for us to get to the next level as an
environmental movement if you will it
has to be about every American every
citizen the world we have to recognize
it we're all in this together we can no
longer say okay they're the
environmentalists they're going to take
care of the problem or technology
going to take care of the problem
everybody has to take a very hard look
at the way that they're living that
we're living together and figure out how
to minimize our impact on the on the
planet and it can no longer be just
write your check and send it off to
Riverkeeper NRDC or one of these other
groups we've got to have everybody doing
their part and really making those
personal lifestyle changes and choices
in order to minimize that impact and you
know the myth is I think that it's going
to mean a radically it's giving this
radical sacrifice and that we are going
to have to go back to caveman days and
living very frugally and uncomfortably
and so on I don't think that has to be
the case at all i think that we can live
very very comfortable life lives without
having such a big impact on our
environment
I think there is a contradiction there
and what I worry about I think a lot of
us environmentalists worry about is in
this you know it feels very much like
being green living green has become this
incredible fat and all the you know the
good news is is that you know consumers
do have an enormous amount of power and
there's various ways to get corporations
to move in a different direction and one
certainly a one there's certainly
regulations and enforcement of laws and
a carbon tax and and so on but another
way is by consumers making a radical
expression of we want to do things
differently we want different kind of
products we want products that aren't
gonna pollute the environment and of
course that gets corporations to move to
so in a certain way you've seen the real
movement alone behalf of some of these
corporations but i think that the danger
is is if we decide that we can consume
just as much as we always have we just
have to consume products that have a
slightly less damaging impact on the
environment we're not going to get there
we really have to change kind of how we
live our lives and in a more significant
way than that and i think the part of
that is asking ourselves is my level of
consumerism really healthy for the
planet even if it doesn't emit quite as
much carbon and so on there's a certain
point at which we have to maybe not
consume some so so much now this can the
danger of what I'm about to say is it
can sound paternalistic but I would
argue that actually consuming less is is
a recipe for happiness in this country
in a certain way because I think that we
first of all as Americans we run around
with our heads cut off we're also
stressed we work too hard we're running
thin if you will and and we we we don't
take as much time as we should spend
time with our friends and with our
family and to get out in nature and do
things that are spiritually fulfilling
and sustaining and I think that part of
it is that we're also kind of consumer
addicted we all were kind of looking for
the new X you know the new ipod or the
you know the new car whatever it is and
i think that that that tracks from our
connection to nature which i think it's
a really really important one that
really gives the grounds people
I know that when I go out and do a
backpacking trip with my friends and I
get way off in the desert in the
mountains and what have you I'm never
happier I never feel more at peace with
myself I I never feel kind of more
connected to the world around me that I
do in nature and I you know hesitate to
say I'm paternalistic but I think that
Americans frankly would find a more
fruitful path to happiness if we could
kind of back off on they kind of heavy
duty consumerism I think it kind of gets
in our in our way spiritually
well i think that the my governing
philosophy is the as the head of
riverkeeper is very much modeled on john
adams and who founded and ran the
natural resources defense council for
many years and that is the idea that you
hire the best possible people you can
and then you let them go you let them
kind of do their thing and and and use
their talents to to to advance your
mission advance your cause and so that's
very much what I try to do I've been you
know I inherited an organization is
still very much of a mom-and-pop shop
and we've really turned into a
professional organization we're very
efficient we're very lean we more than
doubled our staff we've quadrupled our
budget so I've you know through my
leadership I've helped to kind of build
our capacity and to allow us to confront
more polluters in a larger geographic
area cover more of the Hudson to start
to get involved in New York City in a
way that we hadn't been before which is
which is you know critical and the more
the more places we are the more we can
do our work I've also very much
emphasized the importance of getting
citizens involved in the work that we
can do whether we were when we were 10
people now that were 25 people even if
we're 40 people 50 people you know in
terms of the size of our organization
we're never going to have the bodies to
cover all the New York City watershed
the Hudson River watershed and to
address all the problems that are out
there we really need average citizen to
be part of our effort and then it means
not just setting us checks but actually
attending you know public hearings and
going to community meetings and writing
letters and running for office locally
and helping us fight misguided
ill-advised development projects in the
watershed etc they are a critical part
of the work that we do in terms of
challenges you know the challenge with a
group of our size especially when it's
been growing as quickly as we have is
that you can get very much mired down as
the head of the organization in the
day-to-day running of the organization
and that can be very distracting very
time consuming very energy intensive and
frankly not necessarily a good use of
the president's time you know the person
who's supposed to have the vision of
where you're going and how
the contacts and the ability to kind of
sell the organization and to build our
capacity and raise our profile and
strengthen our stature among elected
officials and other decision-makers you
know you've got to be out and about and
it's going to be doing that work
externally and it's easy in a small
organization to get kind of caught up in
the kind of day-to-day decisions that
need to take place
there's no question about it I think
that the environmental movement in
general has suffered from from seeming
to represent a pretty narrow segment of
society and that's not the case
obviously you know we're out there
fighting for clean water and clean air
and saw we're doing for everybody of all
economic or income levels of all races
of all religions and all political
parties and so on you know there's no
discrimination in terms of work that
we're doing but largely speaking the
environmental movement over the last 34
years has been dominated by by middle
the upper class you know white folks who
have been leaving the charge on this
stuff and I think that's unfortunate i
mean i think there's some kind of
reasonable explanations for that but
it's it's unsustainable because it's had
a couple of effects first of all we're
failing to reach a large segments of the
population that are actually being even
more hammered by environmental pollution
than a lot of the kind of you know upper
middle-class folks who are who are part
of these organizations so they have even
more at stake if you live in a urban
area or a low income area whether it's a
you know or a rural area and so on a lot
of times you're more subjected to air
and water pollution than other
communities I also think that we have
not done a good job of appealing to
folks as well and I think that that's
why we've tended to be vulnerable to the
tree hugger or the kind of elitist type
of tag and I think that we fail to do
that you know luckily I think that
that's really changing first of all a
lot of environmental justice oriented
kamiya organizations are starting and
are actually you know are thriving
around the country and you've got people
like majora who are doing terrific work
and we're really becoming serious voices
and influential players in this movement
but not just in this movement but in
political circles as well and that's
vitally important and it's long overdue
but I
I can't say how thrilled I am that it's
happening now because we're not Amy the
bottom line is this if it's just the
environmentalists trying to do this work
on our own we're not going to do it
we've got to enlarge the tent to have it
represent all sectors of society and
we've got to include everybody everybody
has to see themselves in
environmentalist we have to get away
from the idea that's a dirty word which
is you know what unfortunately longer
our opponents have successfully achieved
is this making environmentalism somehow
you know a fringe activity I think it's
becoming pretty apparent with climate
change especially but all the different
environmental problems we have this is
no longer a fringe issue this is front
and central to how we're going to do
going forward and not just in terms of
our health but also economically and
otherwise so luckily I think the war is
starting to catch on and and whether we
wanted to it or not this is becoming a
world movement and it needs to
it does you know I was not raised in a
religious household so I don't not part
of any you know organized or formal
religion and so for me for a long time
since I was a kid being in nature has
been you know my source of inspiration
and my connectedness to the world and I
find being a nature you know and tensley
a spiritual experience and I just wish I
could spend more time I mean the irony
of course for a lot of us
environmentalists is this work is so
all-consuming and so challenging that
you end up working very very long hours
and and don't get as much of a chance to
get out in nature as you like but it's
critically important and one of the
things i would say to kind of average
Americans in addition to supporting
groups like ours in addition to getting
much more politically and civically
engaged than we've traditionally been in
the past is to get your kids out in
nature and to give them the chance to
make that connection with nature and
with wildlife and to develop a real deep
appreciation for for nature and for the
species that we share this planet with
and also for all the benefits that the
natural world gives us in terms of our
ability to live live life on this planet
and you know and then the other thing
I'd say too is the part of what
motivates this work is that you know to
be honest is an emotional one I have an
enormous amount of anger and frustration
that we humans you know is talented and
beautiful as we are as a species and the
things that we've created in terms of
the arts and music and and even
political systems and figure out a way
to kind of live among one another for
the most part successfully that we are
we are we are also capable of such
destruction and such greedy behavior and
and and that we don't have more of a
moral imperative to not just protect
ourselves but protect the other species
and natural systems that we share this
planet with I I find it disgraceful in a
certain way
and and this is what worries me about
America in particular because we we have
been seen as a model model democracy to
a certain extent although I think that's
less true now I don't think our
democracy as quite as as doesn't meet
quite the high standards that I think
that our founders had in mind these days
but we really have been seen in this
generally a role model for the rest of
the world and the way we conduct our
lives the way we run our economy and and
in particular the way we consume things
and I think that's very frightening and
even though our role has been diminished
and are standing up and diminished in
the last seven or eight years worldwide
I think we still have a big influence
and that's a great opportunity to do
things differently here and to say okay
yeah we did it we did it this way for a
long time we were very rapacious and and
consumptive for a long time and we've
realized that that's not the way to go
and we're going to go off in a new
direction we want to encourage you guys
to do the same thing meeting all the
other countries and of course we have an
obligation to help them do that because
part of the reason to wearing the mess
we're in is because of all the pollution
and problems we've created over a long
long time I think we do have a moral and
economic financial obligation to help
assist in these other countries that are
trying to do to grow economically and
improve their quality of life and so on
to help them make that transition